we're halfway through 2019 and PC gamers
are beginning to lose their patience
with juggling multiple clients when they
just want to find and launch their games
trying to figure out which EA games was
shifted from Steam to origin at tackling
you play and remembering which games are
now epic Store exclusives has been a
cause of frustration for PC players but
there may be a solution answer GOG
galaxy 2.0 which promises to unify all
of your PC games into one very pretty
client I began using GOG galaxy when The
Witcher 3 first came out and while I
loved the drm-free capabilities the
platform itself was buggy and generally
not a great user experience but GOG
galaxy 2.0 looks to be a vastly improved
addition and as the beta isn't open to
everybody yet here's an inside look the
first thing which is really apparent is
that GOG galaxy 2.0 is gorgeous the
visual and functional overhaul is
impressive and heavily customisable
importing your games creates an
insightful and intuitive overview of
your collective PC gaming library and
your PlayStation and Xbox libraries for
that matter currently it's not possible
to import any Nintendo games but for
games on every other platform you're
able to view your achievements hours
played and friends stats among other
things you can also explore your entire
gaming library using custom filters and
such parameters the closed beta doesn't
contain every planned feature and as
it's being constantly updated there are
certain things that don't work as
intended there are general bugs some
missing trophies and progress and
galaxies can occasionally lose its
connection to certain clients but these
problems don't outweigh the advantages
of the platform especially how it
enables the integration of all of your
clients into one this requires some
setup as you need to log into each of
your clients to connect them to galaxy
but if you don't consider capture
software to be your arch-nemesis like I
do it's pretty painless finishing the
process rewards you with a comprehensive
goldmine of your own data and a client
that will never again have you
scratching your head trying to remember
what platform Mass Effect 2 is on once
you link your platforms your library
Auto populates with art playtime stats
and achievements I
found with some lesser-known games there
could be gaps where art is missing but
icon and background art can be imported
straight from your computer you can boot
games from GOG galaxy 2.0 but you do
still need to wait for the original
client to get running in the background
my wait times varied by platform with
Steve improving to be the fastest and
least intrusive third-party platform to
integrate some clients like origin and
you play still insist on popping up on
your desktop when you try and launch a
game from either platform but a feature
is in the works which will automatically
close clients when exiting an Associated
game galaxy does let you install games
straight from the launcher but of course
if you want to buy the latest epic store
exclusive for instance you still need to
take yourself over to its specific store
to buy it the only time you'll really
run into a problem is if you haven't
enabled your clients and games to order
update
I don't auto update my platforms or
games because I still remember getting
yelled at for using up all our family's
data when I was a teenager living at
home so building a game like the
division 2 can mean awaiting for you
plate update and run and then waiting
for the game itself to update and run
bonus points if galaxy also required an
update at launch
fortunately sifting through the piles of
data in GOG galaxy 2.0 to find out which
game I've loved the most time in 145
hours in divinity original sin 2
apparently is a perfectly good time
waster while waiting on those progress
bars generally you'll want to make sure
you are Auto updating so you don't run
into this problem in which case you
should sail right through into the game
with far less waiting around I did most
of my gaming offline and away from
distribution platforms until the 2000s
so while GOG can't paint me a perfect
daughter if ik picture of all the
weekends I spent playing Heroes 3 or Age
of Empires from dawn until dusk there is
still plenty of stats to check out it's
worth noting that GOG galaxy 2.0 isn't
the first all-in-one launcher if you
didn't already know play Knight is an
open source library manager that imports
games from all your platforms into one
and while by all accounts it does the
trick go galaxy 2.0 has some special
editions under it's pretty hood galaxy
includes a bookmark function that lets
you pin games genres or custom tagged
groups to your sidebar
custom tags can be created instantly and
you can group together whatever strange
amalgamation of games you choose there
are also plenty of UI options like
filtering by platform operating system
tags or whether or not the game is
installed the platform is also open
source allowing for community made
plugins which should enable clever users
to expand the breadth of what GOG galaxy
2.0 is capable of overall the process is
as streamlined and well executed as
you'd expect from a beta you can hide
games in your library which I did for
trials and if you own a game on multiple
platforms it'll combine the stats under
one page fear as a space to hold your
half-a-dozen gaming libraries it's
entirely sufficient and missing trophies
or sluggish boot times from certain
platforms don't take away from how much
easier it makes modern PC gaming galaxy
is also intending to integrate your
friends from other platforms into the
client which certaPro access could
extends to sending a message to a friend
on ps4 who receives it instantly but
this functionality is yet to be
implemented a handful of years ago I
couldn't imagine go galaxy working for
me as a replacement for Steam despite
how much I loved the drm-free and
offline play options but Galaxy 2.0 is a
vastly different based it may not have
the library to replace your existing
platforms but the relative ease with
which it unifies all your clients means
that at least for me playing my PC games
through GOG galaxy 2.0 from now on is
looking to be a no-brainer
[Music]
you